[Music]
and faith in humanity restored news
submitted by D'Brickashaw Ferguson a
homeless man spent his last 20 dollars
to help a Stratton woman she's now
raised more than three hundred and fifty
thousand dollars to repay him I saw this
I didn't know that it was real how do
you do that if I was homeless I would
never give somebody 20 bucks let alone
now I'm not and I still want to give
somebody 20 bucks well that's a stranger
because there's a lot of con artists in
LA you know where they always make up
that same story you know but what if
she's hot I don't give a [ __ ] that's $20
my grandma was dope she's like you just
gift from the kindness of your heart you
just let the universe or God whatever
you believe in started up
well I still get from the kindest of my
heart but then I'm giving it to that
dude off of the Alvarado exit with the
pigeons cuz he works for his [ __ ]
life I just do it cuz I feel like at
that time yeah I'm on a good mood today
here is a 75 cents hope you get some
crack hey if you're down and out you
want to get high get high that's a good
t-shirt there too if you're down and out
and you wanna get off on the back yeah
alright so Katie she's 27 years old from
New Jersey
joycie last month she ran out of gas
when she was driving to Philadelphia
Philly yeah to Philly and so she pulled
over on the side of the highway mm-hmm
irresponsible but that would happen
apart for sure oh we that has never
happened to me I didn't say that it
happened to David I said it would you
know that did happen to me and then he
saved my ass because we were in the
kalaxian we saved your ass we were there
so he saved my ass right and then I was
down here at the car you know you and
David you so you were sitting in the
front
you may put in my memory you're saying
if I was in the back and then you guys
are talking and then it's when I first
got the Jeep and I didn't realize that
in the Jeep when that [ __ ] hits eat it's
actually e there is no gift you know to
me it's E is key and that's it so
because in the camera I had hit and then
another quarter and it would still be
good there's no reserve tanking that
[ __ ] that [ __ ] is exact and I found out
that was it oh yeah then you're like oh
I lost gas but it happened so suddenly
you didn't panic about it yeah yeah okay
filled it up it was awesome
and Rio was in the passenger seat of
Bart's car eating yogurt like crossing
her army she was like do we have to help
it I was like babe [ __ ] hate David it
was like oh interesting yes we were
coming back from a lunch or something
mm-hmm left her dinner all right the car
was like yeah straight ASCII [ __ ]
David I hate you never did bad got this
one and I might have to get braces soon
because I think oh we don't give a [ __ ]
about I just gave you a couple and move
on with the story
oh I just found this out I think I knew
braces soon that's all I just wanted to
say that go ahead okay can we say oh she
pulled over on the highway she was
approached by a homeless man named
Johnny who is 34 years old
oh he's a young homeless man I bet you
thought she was cute me hold is a kitty
20 bingo Kevin I seen his pictures so he
offered offered her money without her
asking for it no I didn't think you
thing it cuz I gotta be changed let's
let her explain this story yeah so then
he was a she was approached by him right
and so she was a little apprehensive at
first like what the heck but then Johnny
told her I just go back inside of your
car lock the door
and then so he ended up going to go get
help
she didn't know this but he ended up
going to a nearby gas station used his
very last twenty dollars to fill a can
and then brought it back to her to fill
up your cart
that's crazy doesn't matter if you're
rich or homeless is [ __ ] you're still
trying to get [ __ ] no matter what
that's so true
that's correct you know what the funny
thing is give this guy credit I'm just
being a dick
the funny thing is he comes up to her
and says there's dangerous people around
here keep your doors not come I pictured
your homeless Joe character [ __ ]
cutoff like yeah can we see what the man
looks like and also the girl looks like
because I want to test this theory and I
seen them fail there's Katie and Tony
she is [ __ ] cute I told you she
wanted that poo tank I'll tell you
something else I'll give her her my
shoes my jacket my clothes and that
twenty dollar bill because she is cute
yeah so she ended up so she found out he
did he looks like a wise man who's
beards dope yeah that don't beard yeah
she's really cute there's like an
adventurer like a nature man yeah yeah
how come that guy has a head on his
shoulders like don't try anything funny
[ __ ] well that's her boyfriend
but I'll get to that later
so that's what boyfriend um yeah so well
I'll get through that right now so after
she found out what he did Katie she
still didn't she didn't have any money
to pay him so she promised that she
would come back damn she's hella
unprepared this [ __ ] was boundless no
[ __ ] cell phone no [ __ ] cash I
don't know she didn't have a cell phone
but I'm just assuming just so that the
story sounds better no cash no yeah why
did she listen to the homeless guy in
suede cuz if I was a she has no choice
to eat [ __ ] okay yeah but I would have
caught hey maybe she no she didn't run
out of phone she one round and
everything
[Laughter]
are you ready to fall yeah then she
ended up returning to the same highway
where Johnny stayed with cash snacks and
gift cards and every time that she's
gone she's gone with her boyfriend mark
and so they've ended up learning a bit
more about Johnny wait Johnny got a like
area that he squats that yeah a highway
like that off the highway
that area yeah that's mark territory
yeah Oh like like under the highway I
don't know okay so he has a place on the
highway yeah we don't really summer on
that area
okay okay I'm just trying to picture
this guy's abode okay so the they put
the goal for $10,000 hoping that they
can have a few hundred bucks to book
Johnny a motel for a few nights or you
can clean up and try to get it back on
the streets
but as of right now it's hit almost four
hundred thousand dollars half a
millionaire is he gonna get this yeah so
they're saying that this couple so Katie
and Mark they're they're planning on
working together to give like a good
word on his Johnny's characters to talk
to like landlords and try to help him
get a job so his backstory is Johnny
he's been homeless for about a year he
was previously a certified paramedic and
he's also served in the Marine Corps but
after moving around the country for some
time he went to Philadelphia with a job
lined up and some money to buy a truck
but then soon after the job fell through
and then he was just surviving off a
little bit of savings and so he ended up
losing his paperwork which then made him
unable to work and he ended up spending
on he thought like one night on the
streets turned into a week and then
ultimately now a year of homelessness so
then they were just like after the
couple learned about his story they were
just really shocked cuz they were like
it was just so shocking to see how his
life changed from vacationing on the
beach to living off the streets and
Philadelphia's it's like anyone could be
any of us
yeah it could happen
I want to meet homeless people like him
because all the homeless people I've met
have looking a little bit on the nippy
side cuz we're in a way yeah I wish that
could me homeless people like that
tenants like to help this guy um well
they don't have services out there that
help you get your Social Security and
because they have this in LA where like
people that are down and out and they're
they're they're called at-risk homeless
which are people who are they have
temporary housing but then ya heart like
hard times and then they go on the
streets and then they find it again and
it's back and forth back and forth right
so they lose their paperwork and all
that stuff but there's programs that
help them get their Social Security
their ID all this stuff and they try to
help them find solid jobs well it is
being reported that he started the
process of getting paperwork replaced
okay so he hopes to get a job at the
Amazon warehouse and he's also hoping
that take the test to be recertified as
a paramedic in Pennsylvania or New
Jersey Oh make that happen so I'm gonna
show you guys a clip of when the couple
surprised him with with the campaign the
money that they they ended up getting
which was about a thousand seven hundred
by the time they filmed this this video
so now it's like growing like crazy here
we go a lot of people out there man that
are trying to help
oh wow yeah he has nice clothes last
pocket form or something
and they're not little ones either
seventeen that's my life right there
1764 dollar changes my life
the 769 change I want to be homeless and
have the whole world love me and give me
$500,000 they love you right now in you
well I don't get $500,000 because they
feel like oh I want to help this man
well watch Joe's video man sometime
sometimes you just get dealt a [ __ ]
shitty hand you know the men that must
be [ __ ] subdued like you'll work hard
you went to the [ __ ] military and
then you end up being a homeless because
of just [ __ ] series of [ __ ] [ __ ]
events man but look at how much it paid
off
just so I could feel this joy I would
live that life just so I could feel that
moment where I'm like I don't know if
I'm gonna [ __ ] survive next month and
then I just do a good deed out of the
goodness of my heart but also because
this girl was cute and I think she's
kind of like single and she might give
me a chance but she does it anyway but
who cares I got to save somebody that
day wake up one day five hundred
thousand dollars people love you people
care about you oh man that level of
happiness is so different you know
that's called what gambling that's one
of you uh you want a [ __ ] gamble
gamble Joe I do love to gamble